I partnered with geology who is
sponsoring today's video which means
we'll have an ad from them somewhere in
the middle I've tried to record this
video multiple times but every time that
I do the information is out of date and
then I have to record it again we're
doing it today I'm putting my foot in
the sand okay power world ladies and
gentlemen you've probably heard of it is
a millennial near you beating up animals
with baseball bats and then forcing them
as some sort of sick slave labor to make
a house welcome to Pal world so this
game pal World which is being called
Pokemon with guns but is actually much
more a Survival Game I would call it
Conan Exiles with Pokémon it's much more
like Ark than it is like Pokémon
functionally is definitely leaning into
Pokémon for marketing purposes I mean if
you're going to cling on to anybody why
not make it the biggest uh brand of all
time Pokemon is the biggest media brand
ever it's so godamn big I say
unsurprisingly with my gados over here
and there's like a Pikachu over here and
got two Pokémon tattoos I get it but
palad is very much taken the Internet by
a storm both extremely positively for
the creators and extremely negatively
for the discourse so if you didn't
already know uh from Rock Paper Shotgun
here continues to break records with 1.8
million concurrent players on Steam
which is the second highest ever ever
it's insane in the past 24 hours the
peak concurrent Play account reached 1.8
million the second highest of any game
on Steam ever it took that spot from
counter- Strike 2 and the only game to
reach higher is now play unknown
Battlegrounds AKA pubg pubg is still
pretty far ahead with 3 .2 million and I
actually have no doubt that palor will
have trouble beating that because it is
also on Game Pass the fact that it
launched on PC in Early Access and on
Game Pass at the same time means it's
split across platforms the Xbox
achievement hunt a crowd are playing it
on the Xbox and that is millions of
people it also had an absolutely
enormous weekend selling 5 million
copies overtaking cyberpunk 2077 in
steam's most played games list it's it's
nuts this game is so godamn successful
and so quickly and with that and with
Pokémon fans comes some like extreme a
some some Hefty vital people are really
upset about this game people were upset
with me for playing it and there are a
lot of conversations that have come up
about the game in terms of copyright or
if it's plagiarism or if it's using Ai
and the AI one is the one that I first
spoke about as far as I can tell the
accusation that poal uses AI for its
monster designs actually just came from
some totally like uncredited random on
Twitter who basically just accused it of
that there is no evidence at all that
the game uses AI in any facet the best
link there even is that the studio that
makes pal world has previously made a
game using AI OD and I hate that we're
in a landscape where technically it's
possible that they could be using AI in
terms of asset generation which don't
even get me started on how infuriating
the AI conversation is let's just
sidebar real quick for AI okay not going
to get into the ethics too extensively
because the last episode of my podcast
which goes on this channel which I have
with game director Mike bthl and video
game composer Austin wintery we talk
very extensively about the ethics of AI
in the future but it just sucks so bad
that we're now at a point where we don't
know if something is AI or not I highly
doubt pal world is AI because AI frankly
is currently not that good yet and I
don't see why the company who has
previously advertised a game as using AI
seemingly with a head of Studio who is
pro AI wouldn't just say that PO weld
uses AI but there's no evidence that it
does but it just how existentially
terrifying that we're already at a point
where we don't know if things are AI or
not I've been seeing that with people
talking about doctor photos from Israel
and Gaza they don't know if these photos
are AI on it like this is just wow
that's horrifying the second thing uh
that came out that some of you may have
seen was a Twitter thread from somebody
who basically compared the palor 3D
models to those in Pokemon let me pull
that up for you so this account biofog I
think they might have changed their
username a number of times made videos
uh putting models of Pokemon against
models from PA and seeing how well their
mesh overlaps it says TFW you and your
cousin have exactly the same proportions
they Then followed up and said I feel a
little regretful for using exactly so
flippantly here I was trying to be silly
but I think it gave an incorrect
impression I want to emphasize that
while some elements are similar these
meshes are not literally exact copies of
each other it is time to talk about
geology and your skin it's a new year
you might have had some resolutions one
of them probably should be skincare your
Skin's a whole organ and I know it's
very complicated if you try to get into
skincare just from browsing the internet
it's super overwhelming I found it
off-putting for years that is where
geology comes in where taking the first
step to get interested is the hardest
and they make everything else very very
easy geology is a 29 time award-winning
skin hair and body care company
recognizing Men's Health hype Beast
birdie Esquire asman and many more the
way the company works is that you fill
out a little survey about your skin care
concerns or needs or anything that is
unique to your skin cuz everyone's
unique and then they come up with a very
simple plan for you to follow with the
exact order that you need to use use the
products designed around just a handful
of powerful ingredients that have been
endorsed by dermatologists for forever
that has led them to 7,000 Plus festar
reviews people love the product
basically it's like skincare for dummies
tell them what you need or what you're
after can help you get there right at
the beginning so head to geol log. i/
chanard 70 or you can scan the QR code
that's on the screen and use my promo
code charazard 70 and they will give you
an exclusive 70% off their award-winning
skincare trial set on top of that they
are giving you an additional bonus offer
of up to 30% off one of the skin hair
and body add-on products when you add it
to your trial so scan the QR code check
the link in the description and get
ready for the best skin you've ever had
in 2024 now back to the video um they
then kind of admitted to incorrectly
scaling the models uh and then said I am
doing this because I think it's
disgusting how much power world
glorifies animal abuse which I swear
this has to be a troll you can't be
serious this has to be a joke
essentially there was no evidence that
this was the case either as where it
stands legally I'm not a lawyer um but I
am pretty familiar with Nintendo I think
we all are and I cannot see a world in
which Nintendo wouldn't have already
sued the hell out of this game when it
was revealed in 2021 if they thought
that it was infringing on their
copyright which is a complicated Beast
I'm so certain that Nintendo would have
already taken it down they have come out
and made a statement uh they said
inquiries regarding other companies
games you received many inquiries
regarding another company's game
released in January 2024 we have not
granted any permission for the use of
Pokémon intellectual property or assets
in that game we intend to investigate
and take appropriate measures to address
any acts and infringe on intellectual
property rights related to Pokémon we
will continue to cherish and N each and
every Pokémon and its world and work to
bring the world together through Pokémon
in the future the Pokémon company Rock
Paper Shotgun actually spoke to a lawyer
about this one and there are a few
takeaways in this article it's really
interesting I'll leave a link in the
description but um ultimately cotton the
lawyer that they spoke to said that he
thinks Pokemon and Pals are sufficiently
different that there's no problem
because they do look different in pretty
much every way I mean it's you know I
have a lot of criticism of of game freak
and the way that they make games I think
it's absolutely absurd that Pokemon is
the highest grossing franchise and that
I love Pokemon and that I spent a lot of
money on Pokémon and that at the same
time despite that tremendous amount of
income and that they keep making money
off of me they still release games that
don't function look leagues behind every
other game even on Nintendo hardware and
they're just hideously ugly like it is
inexcusable to me that you can make that
much money and be that successful
release the amount of games that you do
and have the quality be as low as it is
and and the problem is that we keep
buying them right that's the problem and
realistically part of the reason that
nobody is going to be confusing pal
world for Pokemon is kind of the pal
world looks better which is crazy game
freak really be up to some business so
obviously there are some Pals that are
very very similar to Pokémon some that I
think are stretches people are comparing
these two things I mean I'm calling them
in game the one that looks like zerus I
called not zerius the one that acts like
a Flareon I called not Flareon I think
it's called like Firefox or something
something but there are some that it's
like oh you copied it cuz it's a snake
no it's just a snake that's how snakes
look you know what I mean uh there is no
world in which the game Studio who is
making this who has a previous game that
is so clearly just a ripoff of breath of
the wild is even trying to hide that
this is plagiarism and it is a thing
that power world should be criticized
for I think two things can be true at
once one game frequently needs to get
their [__] together and that I am sort
of hoping that the one outcome of this
will be that game freak and the Pokémon
company on Nintendo go oh wow we have
some ual competition for the first time
in our entire lives maybe we do need to
improve the quality of our games archus
very easily could have been a lot more
like something like power something that
actually molded the genre it is a unique
game they made some changes I like Aus I
had a lot of fun with it but it doesn't
push the Pokemon formula I think quite
as much as that I hoped that it would in
a way that something like poal is an
entirely different experience I mean
poal is again it's mostly con and Exiles
it's mostly Ark but it's also got some
Zelda and it's got some Pokémon and it's
got some Elden ring as well kind kind of
with the boss ENC count is and again I
don't think they're hiding that any
plagiarism exists and I don't think this
is a positive I do think the power world
should be criticized for doing this and
I think that they should adapt and
change they should take that criticism
and go okay let's get rid of the ones
that have clearly just copied designs
and come up with our own Unique Designs
like that pressure is good that is one
of the main things worth criticizing the
game for even though it's currently in
Early Access it's also pretty buggy
there are facets of the gameplay Loop
that I find very moring there are things
worthy of criticism plagiarism is one of
them also as an aside I feel like we
always just pretend that Pokemon was the
first one to come up with Pokémon have
you heard of Dragon Quest Pokemon didn't
even invent the Pokemon formula even the
card game magic the Gathering is is just
is Pokemon is directly copied from Magic
the Gathering all of this to say truly I
don't actually know how I feel about po
weld currently I don't know what my
current opinion is on this I feel like I
need to like sit with it for longer I do
think it's a pretty solid Survival game
that does a lot of very smart things
that people are probably going to enjoy
for longer I don't think this is going
to be dead in 2 weeks as the internet is
suggesting I do feel like somebody even
vaguely appearing as threatening to the
Pokémon franchise and thus making game
freak have to consider quality a little
bit more which I don't even really blame
them for to be clear like I don't even
really blame the dev team it's such a
publisher problem that when this studio
makes so much money clearly on not
enough staff and is still forced to
release games every year like why would
you increase budgets they don't need to
we keep [__] buying them I'm a part
of the problem and I really do find it
like existentially terrifying that we're
at a
point where I don't know if something is
actually AI or not like that that
frightens me for mankind like if we
can't tell if something politically
motivated is real or not information
effectively ceases to exist like we
don't actually have information anymore
you can't verify something through an
image or a video which is how we've done
it for so long it's it's so easy to fake
stuff these days I just find that to be
the most terrifying takeaway from this
to be honest and I don't think that
pocket pair is a good ethical company
this doesn't feel to me like one of
those situations where it's like oh this
Indie Dev worked hard and made something
cool and made a bunch of money when you
look at the other stuff they've made
they have very very clearly tried to
copy off of bigger games repeatedly
until one of them became a success it's
a shitty practice like I'm not a fan of
them doing that this is not a company
that I'm like super happy for them to be
rich which they now definitely are even
if I think PO is a pretty solid game
there's no innovation here and there's
plenty of innovation in the Indie space
and of course it makes sense that power
world has popped off in the way that it
has because of the elements it combines
successful marketing you know but it's
kind of complicated I've never seen
anything like it it'll be really
interesting to see if they get sued
Nintendo is a very Su happy company in
my opinion but I do feel like if they
had means to do it they would have
already done it and I'm sure they will
try as hard as they can to be honest
especially considering how exponentially
successful power wal has become but I
also don't know how that will go and
also dear God stop saying you don't like
Ai and video games you have to dislike
specific kinds of a guy you can't
dislike all of it all games have ai